[Musique]
reste un gros machin et nous de pessah
lui aussi en chirurgie qui travaille au
lac saint jean au sud d'abou mistassini
qu à ma mère était une jeune femme paris
donc à l'époque il fallait qu'elle
accouche dans une crèche et les enfants
qui naissent est massacrée genève ont
été données la corruption et surtout
qu'un que certaines femmes autochtones
mon grand-père avec un kill entendu
cette histoire lors des venues le
chercher à la crèche saint vincent
limare amené chez nous et j'étais le
départ mes grands-parents par mon
grand-père en fait que j'aie jamais
appris mon grand père c'est toujours été
notre oui je dis papa et maman j'ai
toujours appelé magali maman je pense
que la voirie qui est meilleure
apparence à m'apporter quelque chose de
très important au niveau de ma culture
dans une histoire de ma fierté ma mère a
toujours pris soin - ayant elle a acheté
à réfléchir et prendre un micro parti
mon grand père qui ne savait trop
comment en plus le jeu va déchirer une
page du catalogue sears est allé au
magasin la baie tout son prestige le
tout à voir ce qui à l'intérieur du
frigidaire
mais je comprends mon grand père il n'y
avait aucune des caisses qu'elle est la
fille venant de bois picard y manger
frais ou faisait imprimer la nourriture
nous c'est pire
il y avait bien été gardé la famille
pour moi c'est quelque chose de très
important mais grand-tante compétente
mais quand ce sont les hommes mes
cousins sont mes frères mais ça à chaque
fois je rencontre mes cousins et
cousines
on s'appelle qu'en fera un petit frein
grinçant
ce temps de transmettre que les gars
mais enfin c'est quelque chose de très
important
j'essaie de faire mes enfants présentent
à jamais ma tétouan dans cette région me
plaisait mais je raconte l'histoire
salika petit peu le méchouar fait fuir à
d'autres lieux je ne me décourage pas
j'ai peut-être un jour mais enfin c'est
0,7 à kerjean
[Musique]